- If I end up being an
accountant, I am just going
to throw this quiz in the trash.
(ambient music)
- I studied acting and
German and entrepreneurship
and did a bunch of different
stuff, was an actor,
was a writer, worked for
an ad agency for a year.
- I was a songwriter and
a musician and after that
it led me into television,
Internet, and film.
- I essentially chose
whatever would pay the bills.
- I really wanna see if
my parents were right
and if I really should have been a lawyer.
- Maybe show me something that I wouldn't
have considered as an option.
- I don't know, I'm kind
of nervous because I have
no what it's gonna tell me.
(syncopated music)
- Oh, which career would you rather have?
This is hard 'cause I
feel like I wanna say
celebrity stylist, but my
heart is saying librarian.
- Math professor, no.
Bus driver, no.
YouTuber, yeah.
Did I win yet?
Nope, there's more questions.
- Despite what my apartment
looks like right now,
I'm organized.
I feel like I'm pretty
good at making decisions.
However, I'm here taking
a quiz to help me decide
on my career.
- Which best describes you?
I think it depends on
the situation probably.
But I'm actually one of
those people who like,
if someone's upset at me,
I need to confront them.
Like, "You're mad at me, aren't you?
"Can we talk about it?"
- You thrive in an
environment where you can
immediately see the
results of your efforts.
- I feel the most confident
in a low-pressure job
that feels second nature to you.
- In the workplace,
you're not afraid to be
straightforward and direct.
- The career for you would
include working in data.
- Directing, communications,
I've done that, it was OK.
- Or the fine arts, hey!
- I think I tried to answer
everything correctly,
but I'm surprised by
how accurate this seems.
- I tutor on the side and I love to teach
and it's something I
considered for a long time
and I wonder if it's
because there's like this
sort of personality clash.
- If you feel lost or
confused about what you
should be doing with your
life, it takes a lot of
hard work to figure that out.
- I think it's a lot more
important for us to focus on
the type of person that
we're actually becoming
and for us to do things that we enjoy.
- Life is pretty long
and you don't have to
stick to one thing.
(ambient music)